millionen abrufe für seine videos unter
anderem für willst du mit mir drogen
nehmen platz eins der album charts mit
seinem album triebwerke
das ist alligator der shooting star
würde ich mal sagen in diesem sommer und
das ist natürlich ein grund für uns ihn
einzuladen zu klicks und er kommt auch
und was muss er tun eure fragen
beantworten natürlich die er in die
kommentare hier unter das video
schreiben könnt oder auch als video
antwort hochladen können noch bis zum 12
september letzte möglichkeit dann wird
sie auf youtube abgeschaltet also out
rein
seid kreativ ließ den im vortex und was
bleibt mir noch zu sagen
bis dann bleibt dran